[Music]
hey you guys happy whatever the hell day
it is today
tuesday i guess right yeah it's tuesday
yeah
all right so
let's talk about
this netflix series that they have going
on yeah we saw two of them right uh no
this is well it was the third one that
wasn't the third one was it yeah it
wasn't we watched it it's three episodes
it was three episodes yeah i watched the
first episode okay on sunday night i
think and then i watched the last two
episodes last night so that was like a
small thing yeah that was like the whole
thing i thought we had another we had to
watch no no no
um yeah so this was the same guy that
directed this joe burlinger i think his
name is he's the same guy that did that
one like the ted bundy tapes so this is
like another in that series uh that came
out like in 2019. he also did a couple i
didn't actually realize this but he also
did a couple of other kind of true crime
legs remember that one that we saw about
the cecil hotel you know about like uh
elisa lam and the
and the water tank and stuff like that
he directed that uh that one as well
like and it had some other kind of
murders that happened to seasonal hotel
season hotel also but yeah so that's
like the same uh guy so this one kind of
has it has a little bit of the same
conceit i guess that the ted bundy one
had in that they have all of these
recently released
tapes of john wayne gacy like talking to
his defense team
like while he was you know obviously
like on trial for the many many murders
that he did yeah dude killed almost 30
people 26 no 33 33 that they know of
okay that they know of
and so it's kind of interesting because
i feel like this one i mean the ted
bundy one did this too but i mean it
kind of jumps around a lot in time so
you do kind of have to like pay
attention to it
and i do kind of feel like the tapes
while important
are maybe not as important as the ted
bundy ones and i'll kind of get into
maybe why that is a minute but
what they do in the first episode it
seems like they're mostly focusing they
do kind of focus somewhat on the victims
although not so much at first that's
kind of like comes into play like in the
later episodes but what they do with the
first one it seems like the you know the
disappearance of robert peace who was
his last victim and the one whose
disappearance that was like the person
whose disappearance they were
investigating where he ended up getting
caught
um they kind of like focus a lot of
stuff around that particular case
because that was kind of how because the
[ __ ] up thing about john wayne gacy
and like i said it's you know i feel
like he's kind of one of the quote
unquote big ticket serial killers so a
lot of people
know a lot of the details or at least
have passing familiarity with them
is that this [ __ ]
got away with the [ __ ] for such a long
time even though
he seemed to be
not even really hiding it all that much
you know what i mean it just seemed like
because a lot of the people that he
killed like a lot of his victims
he would ask them hey come work for my
contracting company and then like two
three weeks later they would disappear
mysteriously yeah he was directly
connected with all of them and he was dr
and like for some reason like nobody
thought that was like a red flag
you know what i mean he just seemed to
like just fly under the [ __ ] radar
for an alarmingly long time i mean
there's
yeah
boys and young men yeah and if it was
girls they they they would have been
onto him quit
yeah i kind of feel like and because of
most of his crimes i mean happened in
the early to mid 1970s and they talked a
little bit about this in the documentary
but because and even and a lot of his uh
victims weren't even gay or weren't male
prostitutes or anything like that but
because of that perception
um
then maybe i kind of feel like
the cops were sort of more willing to be
like well we don't really want to hear
about that gay stuff or they were more
willing to feel like
a boy you know like a teenage boy was
more was more uh likely to just run away
from home which is probably true
but
i just felt like they didn't really take
it all that seriously for whatever
reason it just like took a really really
long time i thought they were running
away
yeah and and the thing about it is that
and i kind of feel like this you know
maybe more so with boys than with girls
but it happened with girls as well and
particularly in the late 60s and early
70s when a lot of younger people were
you know runners to go to california or
whatever um i do kind of feel like they
didn't really take it all that seriously
so there might have been some of that as
well yeah you know they weren't little
kids they were late teens
yeah i mean 15 and up yeah which i think
i think the average age might have been
18 18 or so yeah some of them were as
young as young as 15.
most of them were like if they came up
missing it wasn't like a missing child
it was just a missing person and there
was no body so they didn't suspect the
murder
you know and they just
[ __ ] cops weren't doing their job
well they didn't think of crimes crimes
were being committed they just yeah gone
you know yeah i mean and i know we've
talked about this before yes it's easy
to say like in hindsight but the thing
about it is that until robert peace
disappeared
who was like his last victim
i feel like they didn't even check even
though several of the missing kids
parents had like told the cops hey the
last person that was with him was this
gacy dude who he was working for and
would call like this one uh
this one couple their kid was missing
they called the cops like a hundred
times and said please check this dude
out
and they just didn't even look at his
criminal record because he had a
criminal record for him
yeah waterloo iowa for sodomy like on a
15 year old boy so he'd done it before
and he'd and actually some of the men
that he had you know young men or
teenage boys that he had raped
uh lived yeah and some of them did
report it but
not really much was done about it
because like i said the cops were just
kind of like man well that's gay stuff
we don't want to get it
or something i don't let him do it that
kind of thing
that's what i mean i kind of feel like
maybe that attitude like i'm sure that
wasn't the only factor but
that definitely seemed to play into it
some
it was the times
and also it must be said too that the
victims probably didn't want to report
it either to a large group for many of
the same reasons so i kind of feel like
there was just kind of all this this
perfect storm of all these [ __ ] up
factors that were like contributing to
letting him get away with killing at
least 33 people that they know of could
have been the cops in that area at that
time
the ones that were dealing with this or
were who were confronted with this
didn't want to believe it
yeah i think it's like ah it's unlikely
probably what they probably just kind of
dismissed it no it didn't happen
well and because he was kind of in the
community he was kind of like a
well-known right i don't know if i'd go
so far as says likable because a lot of
people kind of thought he was like an
overbearing jerk
but
you know then then again a lot of people
thought he was like a nice dude and he
was kind of like a community he was you
know in the jc's and all this other kind
of stuff and he's like oh you know i'm
in the the polish parade and they would
sweep people you know they would shovel
snow off people's walks for free and all
this other kind of stuff
and i just kind of so i just kind of
feel like oh nobody wants to think that
somebody like that
is doing that [ __ ] up of [ __ ] like in
their
life you know
gacy has that i i don't understand why a
lot of people don't see it
i think some people i think a lot of
people do but i don't know but casey has
that speech pattern of a pathological
liar yeah you can really hear it like on
this [ __ ] strong all right uh i i
recognize it instantly when i see it
it's
constant lying
the liar is not real convinced of his
lying he's you know what i mean you can
tell that he's very glib glib and and
yeah and um
there's just this speech pattern that
they use
that is just very artificial and kind of
mechanical
and and i don't know why
and it's whenever you whenever they find
these serial killers most of them have
that
yeah that same speech pattern kind of
thing there's a
there's no way to describe it
you know what i'm talking about yeah
yeah and like i said it's very apparent
when you listen to his tape sesame says
is there any admittance by gacy in this
series no no everything i've ever seen
of him is always innocent somebody else
did it it's always kind it's not so much
that it's not he's not saying that he
didn't
bring the boys home yeah he's not saying
that he didn't have sex with them he's
not saying that he didn't but he's kind
of arguing implying
that it was consensual
and also sometimes
he'll say something like one of the
victims that he killed it might have
been robert peace or the one that
happened before that i can't remember
but he um you know put some like uh you
know the rope and stuff like that around
their throat and then like he got a
phone call in the other room like for
his business because he ran a
contracting business and he went in
there and he's just like oh when i came
back in he was dead it's always just
kind of like yeah like he blacked out
and it's like you know oh the next
morning he was just dead i don't know
what happened it was just that kind of
crap like an excuse
really do you really think anybody is
buying that [ __ ]
i mean it's always some excuse that lets
him off the hook
yeah and there's 30 something of them
33. i'm like i very much doubt that that
happened 33
know what happens times just i just
dudes keep dying offered this kid a job
at my contracting and then all of a
sudden he was dead and raped and
strangled in my house i have no idea
like what could have happened and i
don't know why all these young guys are
all good-looking i don't know it's just
every time there's young good-looking
guys they just they die i don't i didn't
do that i kind of feel like that's the
way he's [ __ ] i mean what i got from
him like okay now one thing
he didn't really i mean i kind of feel
like ted bundy it's been a while since i
saw the ted bundy tapes ted bundy's ones
were
a lot creepier because he did seem ted
bundy seemed to have like a lot more i
don't want to say insight that's not
exactly the right word but he seemed
like more
aware of what he was doing and aware of
why he was doing it i kind of feel like
gacy
i'm not sure if gacy believed his own
[ __ ] it's like hard to say because
he comes across as just very
flip he's very artificial he's very i
kind of feel like i'm not sure if he
actually believed because he did say
like on some of the tapes that i you
know i don't know i didn't do any of
this and i'm gonna get away with it just
you wait he's just like saying stuff
like that i don't know if he actually
believed that or if he was just
or if it was just like bravado because i
kind of feel like the way that he grew
up
um you know it with his dad being really
like abusive and
his dad you know calling him queer and
like beating the [ __ ] out of him and
stuff like that thinking he was like
faking illness and all this other kind
of [ __ ] to get attention and
him wanting to like please his dad and
feeling like he never could
and i wonder if
him being that being the way he is was
just kind of like he's terribly like
afraid he's very insecure he doesn't
really seem all that intelligent he
doesn't really seem to have a lot of
insight into his own
uh you know into his own psychology so
everything is just bluff and bravado
like everything is coming across as a
sort of like fake arrogance that's kind
of like what it's that's what hit the
what he was saying like struck me as
yeah they're asking me what raider would
say
what dennis would say dennis would say
this
yeah
although you guys make me laugh
yeah i may have sexual problems but at
least i'm not a homosexual
that's what he would say yeah he would
say he would say yeah that guy yeah
he tried to make himself look
respectable you know
working for the jc you know he was in
the jc's and but you
know it was all a facade
he was a homosexual
yeah
and the thing that kills me about daisy
too and he says this on the tape too
is that he told his wife because he was
married a couple of times
yeah he told his first wife that um that
he was bisexual yeah now
i'm not sure he knows exactly what that
word means or if he's just like
obfuscating like on purpose because he's
his definition of bisexual was you just
kind of like have sex with whoever
whatever and without any uh love behind
it that's what he said but he he made it
very very clear in his tapes that he
hated
gay men
i'm bisexual i buy you something and you
get sexual
i'm buying dinner and you're getting
sexual that's nice
but uh but yeah so but that's the thing
it's like
it's weird that
gacy i mean it's not weird i know why he
does why he does it but
he says to his wife he basically um you
know that he's bisexual so he likes to
have sex with me but he's
but he's like he's not gay oh no i hate
those people yeah i hate those people i
think they're disgusting and i'm just
kind of like dude yeah my man yeah my
dude him and him and raider hanging out
in prison and [ __ ] [ __ ]
like
raider be like yeah yeah i put on
women's clothes but that was just to
take pictures i it's because i didn't
have a woman at the time and i was just
trying to
put put my artistic message out there
you know it's not like i enjoy wearing
women's clothes or anything you know no
of course not no
and that's that's the same vibe i get
from casey where he's just very adamant
that he's like that he hates
gay men he hates that whole thing and
yet
he is engaging in i mean after his uh he
did have sex with his wife because they
had kids and stuff but
you know not much though yeah at one
point he says to his wife yeah we're not
having sex anymore and i'm gonna go and
she knew that he was having sex with
boys or she suspected
and so but so i don't think that he had
sex with women after that point and yet
he was just out there saying like how
much he hated gay men and i'm just kind
of like
what is your [ __ ] and it's
self-hating that's what i mean and it's
just kind of like and it's so obvious to
everybody else and it's the same thing
like with dennis raider like wearing
women's clothes and getting all like you
know
all stiff about it it's just kind of
like
look everybody knows why you're doing
that [ __ ] it's like and you denying it
just kind of makes it
sound sort of more hilarious because it
seems like you don't really have any
idea that you're not fooling anybody i
don't think dennis was gay though dennis
was just cross-dressing no yeah those
are two different things
and that's not what i meant i meant that
i didn't mean that dennis was gay i
meant that you know he had like a fetish
for transvestism but like i said that's
that's not usually the same thing
usually transvestites are usually
straight but um but yeah the the fact
that they're in such denial about it and
they're trying to be so well i've never
you know what i mean and so like i said
gacy being that way
um like i said which might have stemmed
a lot from
the time but also
you know being
having his ass beat and colin is having
his dad call him
you know queer and stuff like that when
he was a kid and getting the crap beat
out of him i'm not like excusing it but
his dad was super abusive
so
yeah you know i i i don't know it's just
funny that it's very very obvious to
everybody else why they say what they
say but they think that they're so much
cleverer than everyone else and i
definitely got the idea
that gacy who like i said never struck
me as particularly bright
um
you know he seemed a pretty average
intelligence to me he didn't seem like
smart or mastermind or anything but he
was definitely one of those guys that
thought he was like super super smart
and clever even though he obviously was
not
um the only reason that he got away with
what he got away with for such a long
time was not so much because he was
super smart or a mastermind or anything
like that it was just circumstances you
know i kind of feel like nobody really
suspected him because he seemed like oh
neighborhood nice guy
um and honestly he had killed some
people i think his first victim was
1972.
um
you know when he killed a couple people
in
in the years between 1972 and 1976 but i
kind of feel like it ramped way up after
his wife left him like his second wife
left him in 1976 like it went kind of
off the rails and then after that like
neighbors did start to report him acting
really weird or not really giving a [ __ ]
anymore like if he looked weird i kind
of feel like prior to that he
was sort of maintaining a facade of
normalcy that people were kind of mostly
falling for
you know but but he did
i mean even they have there's interviews
with a guy on there who
um
he actually was uh almost raped by gacy
when he was how much how old did he say
was i think he said he was 15 16. but he
was in high school
and uh and he's still and he's like an
old guy now and he was just still like
really really upset about it he's like
was like the [ __ ]
can you imagine it's like it must have
been like the most horrifying thing
because what gacy would do
was that like i said he would he had an
angle he's just kind of like he wasn't
just cruising around he did that later
um you know he would pick up kids that
you know needed a ride or something like
that yeah he would torture these these
guys yeah and i kind of feel like they
don't they didn't talk about that too
much like they do kind of go into that
stu in the in the documentary but i kind
of feel like i kind of wish that they
had gone into that more
bdsm hardcore [ __ ] bdsm [ __ ] sexual
[ __ ] he due to him well and he did some
[ __ ] like he did some [ __ ] like dean
coral did too and he got the idea from
dean coral where like with the the rope
or the the board with the rope on it
like ty and people he was doing that he
was doing that kind of [ __ ] too yeah um
you know like sticking huge things up
like people's butts and stuff like that
and just like how did he how did he
usually kill him strangling
strangulation
um and he would take a long time doing
it too and like another thing he did he
would like sometimes give them drugs and
wake him back up or he would partially
drown them and then wake them back up
and i mean he just like hours and hours
and hours and he would just like abuse
them until and and like i said he had an
angle it wasn't always
oh he just went down to like um like bug
house square which is where a lot of uh
you know kind of male hustlers and stuff
but also just street kids homeless kids
stuff like that would hang out because
it was a greyhound bus station there so
later on he would start doing that but
prior to that like i said he had a
company and it was actually a successful
contracting company
and he had like all these teenage you
know 20s guys working for him
so he had a legitimate thing where he
could go up to young guys and say hey i
have a contracting company and you can
come work for me and he did have work
for them and then if he found one that
he liked he would just you know you'd be
hanging out with him one day nice john
wayne gacy he'd have a beer with you and
then he'd say hey want to see a magic
trick
and then he'd put some [ __ ] handcuffs
on you and then you were in big [ __ ]
trouble
and driving force was [ __ ]
self-hatred he asked me i kind of feel
like it was yeah he was a pathetic
little fat man all right who was just
not
impressive in any way it started
early in school
where people just blew him off he was
the kid that you did not pick to be on
the team you know what i mean he was
just
people [ __ ] made fun of him and um he
was he was gay
but he didn't want to hide he wanted he
didn't want to admit it his dad was
[ __ ] real hard on him so um
he grew up to be a just [ __ ]
vicious [ __ ] who's trying to
damn
prove something to himself what a tough
guy he is
you know he does it by
torturing
dudes he was attracted to
that would reject him so you know
why not torture and kill him that's what
he's doing in his mind that's how he
you know that's how he rationalizes it
he did let one of them go i think
yeah and then one that one guy begged
enough sometimes he'd let him go that
one guy um who they actually talked to a
little bit like and they think of on the
third episode yeah that guy was like
horribly horribly he um
gacy got him with uh chloroform and his
face was all burned yeah and um yeah he
raped him and like he dumped him in a
park yeah and that guy actually went to
the police and said hey this happened
and then he said i'm gonna go uh find
gacy myself because he remembered kind
of what the what the exit was and where
what the car looked like so he like went
and
positioned himself at that exit and said
i'm gonna wait here until i see that
motherfucker's car again and then i'm
gonna get his license plate and i'm
gonna go back to the cops and tell him
like who the [ __ ] yeah
okay yeah
so so yeah yeah so this is uh
overcompensating you know he's
overcompensating for [ __ ] and he's got a
lot of [ __ ] self-hatred
but that doesn't [ __ ] was a
monster
you know yeah
and the fact that he couldn't even he
was so [ __ ] and he's a lizard like
kind of like a robot you know yeah he
didn't even when he i he seemed to j i
don't know if he genuinely believed this
it's hard to tell like i said because
he's very the way that he talks is just
very shallow and kind of off the cuff
and he doesn't like i said he doesn't
seem to have any particular insight into
his own behavior but he thinks that he's
smarter than everybody but he's clearly
not
and then like just the way he talked
about these kids
was just
i kind of feel like he's like well they
came to me needing a job or something
like that so therefore they're like my
property type of situation he could just
do what he wanted he did not give a
single [ __ ] [ __ ]
about them as human beings at all he
just saw them as just a thing
and he would just use him and throw him
in the [ __ ] crawl space and even when
he was going to because he was in prison
i don't know if you guys know he was
went to prison in 1980 and he got the
death penalty and then he just like
appeal appeal appeal appeal appeal uh
and then they finally um killed him in
1994 but it's like he would never
uh fess up to anything
he would never like he kind of did but
he always like you know kind of put the
responsibility on something of something
else
you know what i mean it's almost kind of
like
on some of the victims he said oh they
attacked me first or something like that
he would always have some kind of
mitigating
circumstance because he didn't want to
take responsibility as always i've got
we've gone over this one we've done full
shows on serial killers it's never just
one problem the [ __ ] have a lot
of problems at once yeah i mean
otherwise more people would be doing
this yeah and otherwise there would be a
lot of these guys and there aren't
you know it was a bunch of physical
factors upbringing mental factors and
just
he was he was kind of physically and
mentally reject
yeah and he was
kind they were his dad was hard on him
uh he was just kind of unlucky and then
it just uh he was self-loathing and uh
he just started imploded in on himself
and [ __ ] turned into a monster
which um that's sad but doesn't give you
the right to [ __ ] kill people because
you're exactly
it's you know
but he didn't have a deep consciousness
these guys are all kind of robotic
lizard-like that's where that
pathological lying [ __ ]
uh uh speech pattern that you hear
everybody that i've ever [ __ ] met
that has that speech pattern is a lizard
they're not even it's a lizard person
they're not real people they're more
like an ai robot remember that kid that
used to [ __ ] track me down the club
constantly and tell me about him going
to the army little skinny kid he's
always showing up with a new girlfriend
overweight yeah yeah
he had that [ __ ] speech pattern bad
that's why i kept giving that kid to
cole's shoulders like look okay thanks
man i got to go never could get but he
was one of those
if remember that yeah yeah i could yeah
i remember he's a little skinny kid
probably about 19 20. he's old enough to
get a club so i guess he would have been
21 and he tried to get in the army and
kicked him out and then he just keeps
showing up and showing up and showing up
and it's like i'm his lost long friend
and like dude i don't know you yeah you
know
but he had that same speech pattern
which is immediately [ __ ] red flag
but nope they'll want to know you dude
another thing about gacy too that i kind
of feel like is it wasn't just being
self-hating gay and being like
not wanting to be like that
i kind of feel like all he wanted maybe
because he didn't get it from his dad i
don't really know but all he wanted was
adulation and attention that's why he
went into politics that's why he went
into jc's that's why he was the guy that
threw all these big backyard barbecues
that's why he was a clown that's why he
wanted attention he wanted everybody to
love him you want to be better than
other people you know he was just one of
those guys and i hate these kind of guys
honestly even if they're not serial
killers but just kind of those big bluff
like hey ben that's slapping you on the
back and [ __ ] and i hate it i hate that
and you can always tell that that
person's not really like that it's in
front exactly putting on exactly
that's why i don't like it it's totally
artificial
it's a it's like a spider like hey
yeah you're right yes gotta hate that
putting out a web and things putting out
[ __ ] displays to you know attract
prey you could tell it it's it's not
real yeah they don't believe in what
they're doing that it's a facade yeah
and you can see that they feel it's a
facade it's it's a very used car
salesman kind of it's very like
slimy kind of yeah
it's just i don't know it makes me feel
creepy like people like that you feel
creepy
and i think they think they're better at
it than they actually are because
they're not like i said they creep me
further because they're lying and they
don't believe it yeah and they're hoping
that that you are believing it yeah i
get that feeling
uh thank you very much camp guy awesome
show he says thank you yeah somebody
says up here gacy had a whole lot more
souvenirs than what they should on the
series yeah the thing about this is that
i kind of feel like i'm glad that this
series it's three hours but there was a
lot of stuff in it that they didn't
cover but like i said it's only three
hours he killed 33 [ __ ] people and
they couldn't really focus
on each
of the victims like in turn so they
mostly focused on him they mostly
focused on uh you know the investigation
into robert peace like how they ended up
catching him and then they would kind of
go back and talk about like [ __ ] that
happened like in his past and then they
would talk about the tape so they talked
a lot to his defense attorney they
talked um about to the prosecution team
the investigators that worked on it
stuff like that so it's a little bit of
a different angle but
rereading because i was like well i want
to read through like the wikipedia page
real quick like before we did this show
because i was like i couldn't remember
like exactly all this i know we did a
show about them a long time ago but i
couldn't remember like all the details
and yeah they did leave a lot of stuff
out this dude did have
they kind of mentioned it in the show
they said yeah we found like a class
ring and they found like some driver's
licenses and [ __ ] like that like from
some of the victims which made them
suspicious
but they don't you know it's i don't
want to say it's like a shallow but it's
just like a different slightly different
focus i guess than some of the other
ones so don't go into it thinking it's
going to be
you know the end-all be-all because
there's a lot of stuff they did kind of
leave out i wanted to say something
before i forget
christopher walken in um dogs of war is
on for free
with uh on youtube which means that it
may be on um
uh amazon prime for free
that's a good movie yeah yeah i never
saw what he
he
[ __ ] christopher walken has a
mercenary
and he looks at you and he goes how dare
you how dare you how did you stick that
thing up yeah yeah okay uh rick shaw
says how do people that barbecued at his
home not smell all those bodies well he
did use quick lime
and it's i was kind of thinking that too
you think like the whole [ __ ]
neighborhood would stink but i mean he
did like use quick lime and maybe that
helped but they didn't actually smell
the bodies until the cops like i said
they were looking for robert peace the
last victim and they actually got a
search warrant they actually had to get
two because they didn't find anything
the first time but they uh they had one
search warrant and then
one of the cops like went to the
bathroom and smelled decomposing corpses
like coming through the heating duct now
they said when they'd gone to the house
before maybe it had always been cold
because you know that's it's outside of
chicago so maybe people didn't smell it
because it was cold i don't really know
but it's that's you think that it would
like really really smell
um rickshaws and i will have to watch
the cecil hotel one now yeah that one
was actually really good i remember that
one uh caleb wilson says how's tom doing
i recently finished the road rage
episode it sure was something else
yeah tom got like really really drunk
and showered yeah i don't remember uh
yeah i know you know um grandpa's hammer
said self-hating men who dabble in
gayness but hate gay men is as common as
snow in alaska yes it is yes it is yeah
case in michigan recently where dude met
a gay man online then cut his throat and
ate his genitals damn yeah i kind of
feel like that probably happens a lot
well and like i said maybe it doesn't
haves a lot you think that has a lot i
don't know well no i mean
that's not what i meant i didn't mean
like cutting through eating people's
genitals obviously that doesn't happen a
lot thank god but you know what i mean
it's just that kind of thing like where
men are like i'm not gay i'm not giving
it like i said it's probably less
prevalent now because like now nobody
cares if you're gay or not it's like not
you know a big deal but particularly i
think back in the 60s and 70s when it
absolutely was a big deal um yeah you
were gonna get this where it was like
i'm totally not gay i'm totally not gay
you know just like even though i have
sex with men and kill them and [ __ ] like
that like [ __ ] casey did that [ __ ]
there according according to [ __ ] one
one program that i saw that kind of
explained
that attitude was from that generation
that came out of the came out of the 50s
yeah and during the 50s there was kind
of like an anti-gay mccarthyism that
went there it was like it was like
instead of witch hunting they were like
gay hunting oh yeah who was the gay guy
yeah but before that they evidently that
wasn't that big of a deal um well like i
said [ __ ] like that is pretty cyclical
yeah the 20s and the 30s early 1900s
evidently it was real common a lot more
common i mean it was still illegal back
then but i don't think it was i don't
think they were looking for it no and uh
it it always existed yeah of course um
it kind of like you said it goes in a
cycle of whether or not it's acceptable
or not
or what they're going to do to you about
it
yeah
cess b says i love how rape pedophilia
torture and murder are not the shameful
things with casey homosexuality is this
yeah homosexuality is joking about her
which yeah like i said it's just kind of
like oh well i'm not gabriel but yeah
i'll totally like [ __ ] rape and
strangle
dudes raider would have went yeah he's
gay
i just do not get i do not get the
psychology of these people
well the thing that kills me is that you
think what do you think man what what do
you say about that well he's gay you
know of course
that's yeah and i can totally think
you know
and i kind of feel like raider would
have because you know what a [ __ ]
snot that dude is dennis yeah that he
would have been like
looking down on gays yeah he's like well
you know
yeah
he would have thought [ __ ] debt he
would have thought um [ __ ] casey was
a [ __ ]
he would have
dennis was big you know he's about six
something probably i think he's a pretty
sick big dude yeah
and uh physically imposing not not casey
gates was a little fat guy and [ __ ]
raider would have looked at his nose at
him how would that thing
hey another thing you [ __ ] raider
would have said bad about it well he's a
democrat
well yeah
he's a democrat so yeah that would have
been that would have been another one
although somebody was saying earlier
that [ __ ] raider [ __ ] wouldn't
doesn't didn't like wouldn't have liked
him because gabe was against the bible
or something yeah uh
raider went to church but he wasn't
religious uh that's just a facade yeah
it was he was from it was just facade
what was important to to
charles ray or dennis raider was to look
totally acceptable and mainstream
to
to the community at large yeah needed
the wife the kids the white picket fence
going to church on sunday some kind of
uniform some kind of an official job
cherry respectable yeah yeah that and
that was just part of
his camouflage
he'd go out and take a 12 year old girl
and hang her and jerk off on her booty i
mean
the bible says the bible's against that
too you know
i mean about it i kind of feel like it
doesn't say that but i kind of feel like
it's implied right yeah yeah please
don't do that so he did that so yeah
um no
no raider was a [ __ ] monster
all these guys are monsters well the
thing that's and this is kind of going
back to what i was saying earlier about
gacy where you know yeah he was real
involved in politics and stuff but he
didn't really seem to give a [ __ ] one
way or the other about politics he just
wanted everybody to like him and he just
wanted to be popular and kind of famous
and he liked it because he got a lot of
adulation and he knew famous people and
you know what i mean i don't really
think he gave a [ __ ] about
politics otherwise it was just a a
method for him to again maybe a little
bit of camouflage although i don't
really even think that he was thinking
about it that
in that calculated fashion i think he
was just oh this is an avenue where
i'll be popular and people will like me
and i can go around and like shake hands
and do [ __ ] pancake breakfasts and
everyone will think i'm a swell [ __ ]
guy you know what i mean yeah i kind of
feel like he was doing that somebody in
there is quoting me or something that i
said [ __ ] what rated them this is
[ __ ] it's jeffrey art did he say that
he was talking about something i said on
another show
wait what's the last comment
i know but i'm
like behind you okay rob said he was
just like drew peterson that cop who
killed like three of his wives he
sounded just like him oh that dude yeah
yeah that dude
and then mixtape swagger said i agree
that i hate those types of personalities
when i was talking about like those real
those real
fake gregarious dudes that are always
like slapping you on them you know that
type of dude right you know and he's
like hey sport hey buddy hey this that's
god i hate [ __ ] people like that
i just want to punch them in the face um
yeah let's see uh
jeffy reminds me of the uh the herb baum
meister podcast oh my god yeah that was
a while back yeah you guys did a few
years back didn't tom quit his friend if
you're gonna be gay be powerful
i don't really remember that
well that show was a long long time her
biomass that was the guy with the
[ __ ] with the swimming pool and all
the uh the uh the stat the the
mannequins right yeah yeah cause
remember we were supposed to be [ __ ]
haunted yeah that's why we did that like
the her bowmeister from because i kind
of feel like her bowmeister is one of
those serial killers even though he
killed like a [ __ ] ton of people and he
did it like in a really [ __ ] up way
and his house is haunted and there's
just all kind of like crazy i don't even
think they found all the [ __ ] bodies
yeah in the dollar store did he dollar
tree um well no i think it was one of
the dollar stores but i don't know what
was it oh now i can't remember i think
it might have been a dollar
dollar tree dollars there's so many
different ones it might have been dollar
tree or family dollar no i can't
remember which one it was but it was one
of the dollar tree stores like he owned
a franchise of it or some or he started
it or some [ __ ] like that i can't
remember which one was that big man was
it dollar general now we should look
that up yeah we need to look at that i
mean it wouldn't stop me from going well
now is he dead now oh yeah he's dead
that's what i thought i think i'm pretty
sure he's dead i kind of feel like he's
a serial killer that a lot of people
don't bring up even though he killed
like a [ __ ] he killed himself remember
that's right that's right shot himself
in the car went on the run that's right
i forgot about that
he that was [ __ ] creepy because he
had a nice big house kind of like one
you'd have right out here on its own
piece of land private drive that went
and had it out had a [ __ ] um yeah he
had a mother-in-law mansion
mother-in-law house on the side that's
for your groundskeeper and [ __ ] and and
it had uh
a nice [ __ ] modern it could look like
a [ __ ] 80s style kind of mini mansion
with a [ __ ] indoor swimming pool and
a certain wing and everything it'd be
like a place where it's a little dated
you know the architecture but the place
i lived there but i think this [ __ ] was
awesome you could get yeah it was a nice
house yeah you could get those kind of
things cheap now because they don't sell
a lot of times they'll tear them down
and put something else on them
put a new mansion on it because nobody
wants old mansions they want new matches
agnes lamb said it was called save a lot
but not save a lot not to save a lot
that you're thinking because i know that
there's like a chain called save a lot
but this was like that's right but it
was like spelled different yeah so i
don't think it was a chain i think but i
don't think we had any of them down here
in florida i think it was more i don't
remember it was like a midwesterner that
was a weird situation herb kicked his
wife out he was he you know he he went
full gay
so he kicked the wife out and he turned
it into a one-man pleasure palace him
and all his mannequins
and he'd bring his [ __ ] gay friends
over and
get high and squeeze him on the pool
party strangle him to death
i mean some weird [ __ ] then he had him
and then he took him and he had enough
[ __ ] land and enough privacy to
dispose of those bodies he was chopping
up all those bones remember the big
little pile of bones yeah there was just
like i said i don't think they even
found all of them they don't know how
many he killed i think they're still
stumbling across them every now and then
like you find like little pieces of
bones out there still yeah that should
be terrible i bet you'd be creepy as
[ __ ] in that big old house by yourself
and that big old house by yourself those
pile of bones out in the back yeah you
sitting up there like a spider
[ __ ] and he was making money wasn't
he he was making plenty of money or was
he on financial strict straights didn't
he lose a bunch of [ __ ] that's the thing
i think he was actually pretty wealthy
at some point but maybe
well as he brokers yeah i think like as
he was starting to like lose his [ __ ]
marbles yeah um you know obviously drugs
hard to run a business drugs male
prostitutes murder
and and they went through that damn
house they showed that house and it's
because
because he killed himself and they and i
guess the bank owns it nobody ever moved
into it again it'd be like a good place
for urban exploration it has it was
fully [ __ ]
furnished and everything all his stuff
was still in there and and it was like
the 80s decor
uh you know [ __ ] late 80s decor it
looked like
you know that remember that old [ __ ]
stupid looking queen and decor that they
had back then that [ __ ] every rich
person was supposed to have looked like
something from [ __ ] england or some
[ __ ] yeah and the wallpaper is kind of
spooky man [ __ ]
one thing that actually when i was
watching the gacy documentary that i
didn't realize
um because it's been so long since we
did the show
was that um some of the victims are
still unidentified this yeah long you
know this long later actually they um
out of the 33 that they found because
like 27 of them
were
um like in the house like there was a
bunch in the crawl space and then there
were some like on other parts of the
property like underneath like the cement
by the barbecue pit or like in his
garage or whatever and then there were
four of them that he dumped in the des
plaines river he said there were five
but they never found the fifth one
um
but so
for a while there were eight that were
unidentified now they did identify two
of them in 2010 because of dna because
they actually started you know think
[ __ ] they actually started doing like
right around 2010 or maybe a little bit
earlier they started um trying to
identify all the rest of the victims
because they want to you know know who
the [ __ ] they are and like have their
families get a little bit of closure or
whatever uh so they actually did
identify two more of the victims in 2010
and then they just identified another
one in 2021 so there's five left five
victims that they found that they still
haven't identified i was remembering
like one of the most horrifying parts of
this documentary was when one of the
investigators on the case was talking
about um you know going into the crawl
space now see you have to think they
didn't think they were going to find
[ __ ] 27 on
[ __ ] bodies under there they were
just looking for that one guy right
robert peace who had disappeared
and so they go down in there and then
there's just [ __ ] bodies everywhere
and the one guy said
and this they had like a little bit of
footage of it and it's kind of gross but
you can't really tell what it is because
the um you know the videotape was
quality was so bad
but he's like there's this one body that
was in there and it's like any they
couldn't get it out it was like stuck
like down into the thing and he had to
like put he's like this is awful but i
had to like put my [ __ ] hands like
into
the rib cage and like pull it out like
that because it was just like stuck into
the [ __ ] ground and i'm just like
that's [ __ ] horrifying i mean jesus
christ that that guy had to do and like
i said that was a long time ago and that
dude's old now but you could tell he was
like really [ __ ] he was still really
cut up about it i guess as you would be
jeffrey says bow monster lost a lot of
his money towards the end of his life he
was in financial trouble that's what i
thought and i think that piece of
property did eventually sell
but they showed videos up yeah because i
think when we did the show right that
somebody had moved into it and that
because that's where the reports of it
being haunted they had that one guy
living in the caretaker's
house
yeah and then in the main house remember
somebody
so
ghost stories came from when somebody
bought this bought the property
john smith said i thought his house was
raised to the ground yeah gacy's was
yeah uh not to live in that man well
they tore everything out they tore out
all the floors and everything like that
because there was [ __ ] bodies
everywhere yeah
you you couldn't live with that cop said
when he went down that crawl space with
that flashlight there was worms red
worms up on the surface yeah and when
the flashlight hit him though
he said he'd never seen that before
never saw it again either because the
the the soil was just so rich
in those [ __ ] body nutrients that the
[ __ ] worms were [ __ ] having a
field day
i mean can you imagine just going in
there thinking i mean they were pretty
sure they were gonna find at least one
body because they had smelled one and
that's a very distinctive smell yeah um
and as i said at that time they were
only investigating one disappearance
so they were like okay well maybe we're
gonna find that guy and then can you
imagine like going down this [ __ ]
crawl space and then he's just like body
after body after body they were [ __ ]
everywhere it's just like well it got to
a point where
well that's why gacy started dumping
them in the river because he ran out of
room yeah didn't he have some in between
walls
no okay that was another one no he did
um most of them were in the crawl space
uh one of them was under like a um like
some concrete that he poured in his
garage which was kind of like separate
from his house like on the other side of
the driveway uh one of them
or one or two of them were like under
this uh concrete thing that he'd poured
like under a barbecue pit
um and then after that he's like oh well
i thought about putting them up in the
attic but i thought there would be
leakage right yeah so then he started
like taking them and dumping them in the
river
so he did actually like admit to doing
that kind of stuff but yet in some way
and even when they were gonna when he
knew that he had the death penalty and
he knew that his appeals had been used
up and he knew they were gonna [ __ ]
kill his ass
he was just kind of like
he didn't give a single [ __ ] he was just
kind of like uh well i got the last
laugh i got away with it all that time
hahaha he was just like that and i'm
just like oh my god
i wish there was a hell but i know
there's probably not but i kind of wish
there was just that he could [ __ ]
jesus it's scary how easy a person can
disappear we talked about it on the main
shows before
it's a lot easier if there's no family
if you go after a person that has no
family or the family doesn't give a [ __ ]
because uh like they're you know drug
addicts and they don't have a good
relationship with the family the
family's long gone
because um the person disappears and
there's no even missing person report
ever filed
nobody knows the person's missing yeah
so there's no indictment or
investigation the cops aren't even aware
the weird thing about this one though
and like i said yeah gacy did later
start targeting you know runaways and
stuff like that but
a lot of his earlier victims were like i
said kids that he'd asked to like work
for him and so he had
a relationship with them prior and a lot
of them just had like regular home lives
so a lot of those kids were reported
missing yeah it's just that they didn't
know where they went nobody really knew
what they went and i mean you'd think
that gacy would have been right up there
on everyone's [ __ ] number one suspect
but they didn't really get on the ball
until a lot later and actually one of
the cops that investigated the case
on the documentary he even said you know
i don't like to say anything shitty
about my fellow police officers but he's
like i kind of feel like they really
dropped the ball on this one yeah you
know in the sense that all these people
disappeared and they were just kind of
like ah they just ran away oh they'll
come back it's like they're teenage boys
you know that's just what they do yeah a
lot of those green river victims
a lot of those weren't even reported
missing they just found the bodies
you know some of them were reported
missing but
they just knew that that was a body dump
they just kept going down there and
finding more and more bodies yeah
you know
but if they if those bodies weren't
found that you never would have known
those people ever existed
because their families didn't know they
were gone and they didn't have any close
friends that missed them when they
vanished
they were like what happened to that
person she must got locked up you know
yeah i mean you think how many people do
you actually
know walking around out in public how
many of them you keep track of you don't
keep track of any of them they come up
missing you never know
they're missing yeah
you know yeah i mean unless you have you
know you live with a family or you live
with or and you have like a job or
something like that
you know if you just kind of live a
transient lifestyle or you have the kind
of job where no one's really gonna
notice if you're gone for a while
then
yeah you could go missing and then your
family one day might says you know i
hadn't heard from them about eight years
where'd they go they go oh last last
third and last
time they ever filed anything was up in
wichita kansas that's lasted you know
nine years ago we don't know where they
are yeah
that probably happened that's it yeah it
probably happens a lot no missing
persons the cops aren't looking for them
they don't know anything well i mean
especially if you know especially if the
person is like estranged from their
family or they're older they're an adult
they're adults right yeah you know so
it's not like anybody's gonna because
honestly if if you're a missing person
they don't even really like to if
they're an adult they figure you have
the right to take off if you want to
unless there's like really really
suspicious circles now it's a lot easier
because they're these computerized yeah
you got [ __ ]
cell phones and
online records of transactions and
so it's a lot easier to locate a person
or to know if a person is active
if a person has no internet
or electronic signature they're dead
i mean you would think that's an agent
it's really really difficult to live in
this day and age without if you're not
doing atm transactions or [ __ ]
instant money type transactions then
you're dead
pretty much i mean i kind of feel like
yeah so in that way i do kind of feel
like it's a lot better nowadays because
back in the 60s and 70s as we said you
could get away with a lot that's what
and probably maybe that might be a
factor too and why you saw that type of
cereal killing more than you do nowadays
because it was so much easier for people
to just like pick people up and no one
would even know they were gone you know
scary i predict a lot of this kind of
behavior will never really go as it
get as big as it used to you know with
these [ __ ]
five plus
body counts you know for serial killers
it's too hard nowadays
electronics
yeah and the thing about it is two or
three or four but they'll get you so
you'll never get up to 30 or 40 like
casey you know yeah because that's the
thing i mean had there been the internet
back then it never would happen i don't
think he would have i mean there's no
way he could have killed 33 people
without somebody finding out about it
yeah and i'm not saying that people that
that monsters aren't around they are
those kids they get caught those guys
would have all had cell phones yeah they
would have known that the cell phones
went dead
yeah so they would know that those kids
came to a bad end there had been an
investigation who'd these guys know what
they all have in common gacy
that's right where they'd go yeah and
they'd [ __ ] they said you know last
time these phones were ever active they
were pinging off these towers here
and it's only going to get more more uh
uh the security will only increase
increase increase
you know the internet the [ __ ] the
internet of things will eventually come
you won't be able to get away with any
of this
john smith said in the uk police digging
up fred west's garden yeah i remember we
did those [ __ ] we're expecting
to find just one body the police officer
digging said either this girl's had
three legs or we have something more
serious here yeah which is
gallows humor but yeah it's pretty
[ __ ] up john smith also says uh that
one of gacy's employees was later
convicted of being a serial killer and i
have to look into that some people think
casey had an accomplice yeah i think we
maybe talked about that on our show a
little bit that some people think that
uh that went down in the dark along with
the other victims yeah that's possible
like i said maybe that's kind of like
some he killed him yeah yeah there's
maybe some dean coral action going on
yeah
yeah and rick shaw says lots of people
hitchhiked back in the 70s yeah i'm sure
that didn't help either i mean a lot of
people did and a lot of people got away
with it for years and years and they
didn't get murdered but you know i'm not
saying too risky but it's yeah nobody
you'd be [ __ ] crazy to do that [ __ ]
nowadays holy [ __ ] i don't even i don't
even like the idea of like taking a cab
or an uber or something like that i'm
like i don't know that [ __ ] driver
jesus christ that could be anybody uh
granthar says people go missing all the
time and then they find their body 20
years later cars submerged in a river or
in the thick brush under a freeway
bridge and uh you know what honestly i
was watching an old unsolved mysteries
the other day because i've that's kind
of what i put on to relax because they
have like the you know 14 15 seasons of
it on 2b
so i was watching one the other day and
there was these people like a couple i
think and they went missing
and
i'm sitting there like and they're kind
of like laying out the case and i said
they went into a river that was an
accident because it happens around here
too florida happened in daytona when i
was growing up
people were missing for a really long
time there was like no sign of foul play
but they had no [ __ ] idea where they
went turns out they were driving down
the road one night they weren't i don't
know if they were drunk or anything like
that but they just went off the road
went into the river and nobody saw it
and they just been sitting under there
ever since
uh grandfather said tom would make a
superb police detective yeah never too
late bro to live the dream [ __ ] man
coming from an ex-cop that i grew up
with that's [ __ ] funny
uh no man
it may be in another life but that i
could see how that would really wear on
you
i mean i do i wouldn't like battlefield
stuff a lot better a lot more [ __ ] uh
no innocent victims in battlefield stuff
i wouldn't i wouldn't mind um
doing like forensic science type of [ __ ]
like helping to solve crimes but i don't
want to go you know i don't want to have
to deal with the perps i don't want to
have to like go to the scene i know what
i mean but but i wouldn't mind like
working in a lab
like and doing like forensic stuff i
wouldn't mind doing that kind of stuff
but i don't really want to be like on
the front lines of that ground got to be
able to think like a scumbag
yeah
you know and i mean you have to have
empathy you have to be able to put
yourself in the shoes of a [ __ ]
scumbag what's he feeling you know how's
he if anything yeah what's he you know
you know what was motivating him yeah
well that's why this that's why true
crime [ __ ] fascinates me because i they
seem like
alien to me but
the more you read about them the more
you understand how somebody could turn
out that [ __ ] up right yeah but so
it's just interesting for me to read
about how that
how things can go like so horribly
horribly wrong yeah you know what i mean
i like [ __ ] reading [ __ ] internet
fights and watching [ __ ] on you on
youtube in the comment section and it's
it's amazes me granters how
[ __ ] large percentage of the [ __ ]
human population has absolutely no
empathy they get into a fight with
somebody and they cannot
win these [ __ ] online fights because
they cannot empathize with the other
person they can't see from the other
person's point of view if you want to
defeat somebody you have to understand
how they think
it's that way you can
what are you doing what
that way you can um
she's like shut up you guys you know how
they think you can you can predict their
reactions
and uh i just see people [ __ ] the the
[ __ ] that they say
and they're [ __ ] trying to make
attacks on people and you're like no
they don't respond to that it's not what
he's thinking you know just i just think
it's funny
without and and it's it seems like kids
the young ones the younger they are the
less the less prone they are to be able
to put themselves in somebody else's
shoes but they might learn that later
yeah everything is me me me me because a
lot of teenagers are very very
self-absorbed yeah and you're not really
sure how old they are when they're
talking yeah because you just see text
and you're like that [ __ ] has no
idea what he's talking about and it
might be a a 12 year old for all you
know that's right in that you know but
it is funny i do notice that the younger
they are
the less chances that they will ever
score any victory over anybody
first power 100 says in the u.s it may
not happen again but in southeast asia
latin america and africa you still have
serial killers with 30 plus victims yeah
yeah that's true mikhail popkov had 83
victims in russia and surpassed uh
chikatilo who we did a show about we
should probably do a show about that guy
we did chickatillo but uh grant the
grampa's hammer says i suspect i have
mild ptsd from some of the stuff i dealt
with i don't i don't doubt it uh
execution style homicide child rape
people trying to kill me etc so yeah
that's like i said i don't know if
i'd probably want to blow my [ __ ]
head off i'm going to deal with that
kind of [ __ ] all the time i don't even i
mean i like to i don't know if i'd like
to read about it but i'm interested in
reading about it but if i had to like
deal with it every single day i think it
would really man a lot of times their
guys are all dealing with multiple cases
and so that's what i'm doing the back
burners and this and then you juggle and
all that [ __ ] through your mind and then
you got to go out and [ __ ] go talk to
people do interviews
go [ __ ] try to figure out who this
where this person went or what happened
and who did most of it is going to be
simple though most of it well yeah but i
mean every now and then you're going to
come across like some really weird
[ __ ] up [ __ ] and honestly having to
deal with like how i don't think i could
actually bring myself to go to like what
if somebody's like little kid got
kidnapped and murdered and like have
been having to like go tell that to the
parents and stuff yeah no thanks yeah i
don't think i could do it yeah talking
to them it would just be too it would be
too upsetting yes i'm gonna tell you
yeah i don't think i could do that i
mean [ __ ]
people that do do it like [ __ ] that's
amazing but i don't think i could i
don't i don't think i could do it
uh rick shaw says have you seen mine
hunter on netflix jenny yes i have it's
excellent it's about fbi profiling the
start of it yeah it was a great great
show um i think i'll probably like
re-watch it at some point too because i
really liked it uh omri vampire says i'm
still amazed how right you guys hunches
were about the golden state killer years
ago
yeah i mean i
it's funny because i didn't uh go back
and listen to our golden state killer
show like after he got caught
but i remembered that we had made some i
don't know if we like
pegged him exactly but we made some
fairly accurate predictions but it's
because serial killers
tend to fall i mean humans aren't really
that different from one another serial
killers tend to fall in like particular
kind of types and he just seemed to me
seemed to us to be that kind of type
golden state did you talk about yeah
yeah where was that that was the uh
that's d'angelo d'angelo
well just dude could come into it dude
was coming into windows doing recons and
setting up the [ __ ] scene so he can
come back later he knew how to handle
[ __ ]
uh he knew how to take prisoners and
learn and how to handle [ __ ] captured
prisoners i'm thinking commando or a cop
yeah yeah copper cop wannabe yeah or
military i was thinking military or cop
yeah both yeah i think he ended up being
both wasn't he wasn't he military and
police yes yeah yeah he knew that you
could walk around at night with a
[ __ ] weapon
in between houses and go into somebody's
house and and really the chances you
being seen or slim
which is something i found in korea
there'd be [ __ ] 20 of us walking
around through people's backyards with
belt-fed machine guns and m16s climbing
their fences and [ __ ] and not a single
one of them would wake up
nobody would see us maybe 20 of us yeah
making a trail in the ground as we walk
so many guys walking in line you're
tearing up the damn ground and
20 armed men can walk through a [ __ ]
neighborhood and climb people's
backyards and climb over the fences if
they didn't wake up nobody saw us then
one man can do it easy
john smith said a guy in my hometown was
convicted of i think three murders men
he od'd with ghb he bet off grindr
dumping the bodies into church the
police wrote the deaths off as icky gay
stuff
yeah i do kind of feel like that went
and honestly it's i don't know i'm sure
it's better now than it was uh in the
70s like when gacy was active because i
do kind of feel like mail on mail rape
was not really taken all that seriously
largely in the
but between them 1970s
yeah it's like well that's what they do
that's what they do
like he must have like wanted it or
something nasty yeah i kind of feel like
that was like part of it they did like
kind of bring that up a little bit in
the in the documentary yeah um and i
think that was absolutely a factor yeah
as well like why they were just kind of
like yeah we're just not gonna yeah
that's that's their thing that was the
thing that was probably it was a
thinking of the time yeah i mean you
know
uh
zucia zucia
read the book on the golden state killer
it was excellent but also terrifying was
that the one um
was that uh i'll be gone in the dark i
still need to read that it's on my
[ __ ] uh to read list and i still
haven't got around to reading it because
i really do want to read that yeah just
like the serial killer in toronto yeah
it's you know
it's it's sad
it's sad that like
you know depending on the time period if
you
target certain types of victims
it's just less likely that uh anything's
gonna get done about it so you know
[ __ ] man this whole show is kind of
bummed me out no it didn't really bump
me out i mean but yeah so
this was i mean this
documentary like i said it's not super i
don't want to say it's like not super
in-depth but
there's been so many documentaries and
so much stuff made about gacy that i
guess it doesn't really have to be so it
just kind of has an angle they have
these tapes that they found like from
his defense team that a lot of people
haven't heard before so that's pretty
creepy like listen to him his stupid ass
like lies ass off
all that time
um
you know and it was good like seeing the
interviews with some of the
investigators and stuff i just thought
that was really interesting as well but
yeah it's absolutely worth watching uh
so you know yeah bruce mcarthur that's
who they were talking about all right so
um it's tuesday today right yep okay so
tomorrow is our main show
and we're doing a show about autism
spectrum disorders that was what won in
the poll so that's we're going to be
talking about tomorrow evening so
hopefully you guys can
drop by for that because that should be
pretty good
so
yeah i guess that'll do it for the show
today so we will see you guys tomorrow
afternoon thanks for dropping by and
hanging with us